aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour parce
que on commence l'opération peut-être la
plus délicate
suite à l'incendié du 15 avril 2019
c'est le découpage de l'échafaudage qui
se trouvaient autour de la flèche avant
l'instant marc adversité grand-voile
enfants à l'aimer
pourquoi c'est compliqué parce que une
partie des quarante mille tube de
l'échafaudage ou comme fondu avec la
pierre qui elle même a été fragilisée du
fait du brasier qui est monté à plus de
800 degrés et donc les tubes sont comme
aggloméré avec lapierre donc il faut les
découper et ce n'est qu'avec une
intervention humaine que c'est possible
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a des équipes
de cordiste comme des écureuils qui vont
intervenir et avec des si ils vont
découper les tubes les uns après les
autres
l'opération à coeur ouvert en quelque
sorte
elle dure tout l'été dans qu'elle
commence aujourd'hui 8 juin et elle dure
tout l'été
c'est ce qui est prévu mais si jamais il
ya des difficultés sur un chantier comme
ça ça peut toujours arriver via en
septembre le travail continuera
probablement en tout cas ce n'est qu'à
la fin de cette année 2020 que le
diagnostic sera posée pour savoir ce
qu'on va faire exactement pour la
toiture et la charpente et puis donner
l'addition finale de ce que va coûter la
restauration de la cathédrale
[Musique]